the queen's children held a vigil known
as the vigil of kings or the vigil of
princes around the queen's coffin at
westminster hall now this is a tradition
that dates back centuries what was
unusual about the vigil was that
princess anne was part of it of course
the queen had four children and edward
charles and andrew
andrew was actually allowed to wear full
ceremonial uniform along with his other
siblings for this and only this part of
the mourning process but it was a very
poignant moment it was a very moving
moment we had seen
a vigil similar to this in edinburgh
at st giles cathedral but it was very
important to the king that he stood
vigil alongside his siblings tonight at
westminster hall and we now know and
have had confirmation from buckingham
palace that her grandchildren her eight
grandchildren will also keep a similar
vigil for 15 minutes we understand
tomorrow night at westminster hall so
for anyone that pays their respects
tomorrow evening those members of the
public they will pass through
as the king and his siblings and the
queen's grandchildren are standing vigil
we weren't expecting this vigil by the
grandchildren it was quite a last-minute
announcement out of buckingham palace
william was very keen to do it harry too
and again i think many people will be
reading a lot into this because we are
going to see william at one end of the
coffin harriet the other these two
brothers sort of united in mourning
supported by the other grandchildren
their cousins who they're enormously
close to and so i think many are hoping
that this this is the start of a genuine
and long-term reconciliation between the
brothers it's absolutely what the queen
wanted it's sad that it's had to come
through her death but all the signs of a
rapprochement do seem to be there the
olive branch has been extended harry has
been allowed to wear his military
ceremonial uniform and he gave a
statement earlier this year through his
representatives when it was understood
he wouldn't have that privilege in which
he said that his duty isn't defined by
the uniform he wears a lot of people
over here in the uk felt that he
absolutely had earned the right and the
privilege to wear that uniform having
served two tours in afghanistan where
tomorrow night he will get that
privilege and i would imagine that also
will be a very emotional moment standing
vigil by the grandmother who he didn't
get a chance to go and say goodbye in
the uniform he never thought he'd wear
again they are the the younger
generation the new generation of royals
and i think it's going to be an
incredibly moving moment not least
because you're going to see those two
brothers with a rift in an ocean that
has now divided them standing at either
end of their grandmother's coffin i
think that's a moment that will really
pull on the heartstrings i think it's
going to be deeply poignant and very
moving and of course for the members of
the public who are in westminster hall
because they will continue to process
through
i think that moment
watching william and harry at either end
of their grandmother's coffin is going
to be incredibly powerful
incredibly emotional
i think we all hope it's going to lead
to some sort of a genuine and long-term
reconciliation and of course for the
people in that hall who will continue to
process through during that vigil of the
grandchildren well what a moment in
history to witness
[Music]
you